para muchos en líbano es una sensación
de dejar el primer ministro saliente
nayik mikati volvió a recibir la
responsabilidad de formar un gobierno
tras consultar al presidente del
parlamento e informarle de los
resultados oficiales el presidente
convocó a las 17 horas al señor mohamed
najib mikati para pedirle que formará
gobierno según expertos la tarea
asignada a mikati podría llevar meses
debido a los desacuerdos entre las
distintas fuerzas políticas pero la
emergencia económica y social del líbano
no da espera el país se enfrenta a su
crisis económica más grave desde el
final de la guerra civil provocada por
décadas de mala gestión y de corrupción
los libaneses esperan que el próximo
gobierno adopte las reformas necesarias
para contenerla
necesitamos cooperar cuanto antes con el
honorable parlamento para aprobar los
proyectos de reforma necesarios antes de
continuar las negociaciones con el fondo
monetario internacional para alcanzar un
acuerdo definitivo e iniciar el proceso
de recuperación total
el fondo monetario internacional anunció
en abrir un acuerdo de principio con
beirut para un paquete de ayuda de tres
mil millones de dólares exigiendo a
cambio la reestructuración del sector
financiero y la lucha anticorrupción el
gobierno saliente de nayib mikati se
había formado en septiembre pasado tras
un vacío institucional de más de un año
y su nuevo nombramiento tiene un sabor
agridulce para algunos el hombre que ya
ha sido premier tres veces significa la
estabilidad pero para los que exigen un
cambio este representante de una clase
política que ya no quieren